this year on November 15th the world
population hit 8 billion and this guy
helped put us over the edge now I don't
think I was even this excited when my
kids was born ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome Nick Cannon with that
working I did it that's right you're
welcome that's right swindler himself
Whoa man every time we got to talk about
me you gotta talk about my dick Shut up
Nick okay listen I like being caught in
the middle yeah sorry Keenan Nick look
you've been busy this year we all know
that uh and that's why I sent you
um one thing you know as a [ __ ] gift
it's just say what it is a [ __ ]
vending machine full of condoms Keenan
did I get him you got them you got them
on that one doc you got them
the question is are you using it Nick I
hate him you haven't been using it
now this year was the 18th season of
wild now congratulations thank you man
and you've birthed a lot of kids and you
birthed a lot of careers yes now did you
know that some of these people was uh
gonna be huge
amen I I don't know like that's the
thing too I don't even like to and you
know this about me I don't like to take
credit for
nothing like that but I just like to
create the platform it's funny like even
sitting here with you know someone I owe
a lot of My Success to you not to you
not to but to this guy because you gave
me opportunities and stuff when we was
on Nickelodeon but exactly I can't take
credit exactly and I feel the exact same
way to it I could take credit for you I
did take credit for all of them oh you
[ __ ] liar all right haven't I started
you know platform and when you was broke
here we go
[Music]
exact words is Kevin your little black
broke ass would still be on the street
if it wasn't for me and my opportunity
you should be thanking me I didn't
create Kevin Hart no Kevin Hart landed
on you yeah that's right
exactly yeah that's right now Nick
listen on stairs don't mean you just
finished another phenomenal season of
the mass singer what a show what a
success incredible when the [ __ ] y'all
coming to unmask I mean
I wouldn't last past the first round I
think everybody's going to know when I
come out everybody
sound like he's singing through his nose
that's Kevin Hart right there Nick I
will say one thing man and and this is a
opportunity to give you flowers I always
like I want to [ __ ] flowers well in
this case you're going to take them
because I tease you I joke with you
that's our relationship but the world of
creativity that's attached to you and
your craft this is my brother I love him
more than life and you know what like I
said it's about flowers so I got my
brother a Christmas card for him and his
family
[Music]
we've got a plan for all these kids
let's go yeah you ain't grow up on TV
yeah baby don't get money like me
all my kids gonna have sitcoms album
covers yeah you heard it live here on
our show Shannon is pimping his kids uh
this is called a retirement plan
retirement I got kids with Mariah Carey
don't you think there's some talent in
this let's get some Talent
don't just have those kids Mentor the
other 12. it's gonna come it's gonna
come show and a half I'm the only one
clapping for that yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]